[Music]
[Dr. Garcia:] I am Celso-Ramon Garcia, Professor of Obstetrics and Gynecology
at the University of Pennsylvania.
It is my position that the oral contraceptives
when prescribed, used, and supervised properly
present the function for which they were designed
with acceptable minimal morbidity.
[Dr. Lasagna:] My name is Louis Lasagna, I'm a clinical pharmacologist
from the Johns Hopkins University School of Medicine.
In my opinion the unpleasant side effects
and the very real hazards associated
with the oral contraceptives
are of sufficient magnitude as to constitute
a real deterrent to their use as a birth control technique.
[Dr. Segal:] I am Sheldon Segal. I'm the Director of the Biomedical Division of the Population Council
at the Rockefeller University in New York.
I shall act as moderator of the discussion
of this important and timely topic.
[Music]
[Host:] Welcome to the exploration of concepts and controversies in modern medicine,
one of a series of programs dedicated to examining
the uncertain,
candidly recognizing that much of today's
teaching is necessarily based upon opinion,
and that the opinions of eminent physicians
in a given field vary widely.
The National Medical Audiovisual Center believes
that openly airing such opposing views
is a basic responsibility of medical communications.
Dr. Sheldon Segal, Director of Population
Council, Rockefeller University,
will act as moderator of this presentation.
[Dr. Segal:] American women are interested
in oral contraceptives.
They are using these drugs at the rate of
over 2500 tons a year.
It is estimated that perhaps one out of every three American women
married between the age of 15 and 44,
has used or is using the oral contraceptive.
It is being prescribed by virtually every
physician in the country.
On the other hand, we are well aware of the
fact that women using this drug
are not normal with respect to many laboratory parameters
of medical normalcy or of physiologic function.
We know, for example, that several of the
circulating hormones
are not within the normal range in women using
oral contraceptives;
this refers to example to the circulating
level of glucocorticoids.
We are aware of the fact there's an evidence
of altered carbohydrate metabolism for women
using oral contraceptives,
at least a significant percentage of them.
There's also evidence of decreased liver function
as evidenced by certain laboratory tests.
How is it then, that in the face of this rather
perplexing enigma,
physicians continue to prescribe the drug
and feel that they are doing so for the well-being
of their patients?
These are some of the issues we would like
to explore.
We will first have a statement from Dr. Garcia.
[Dr. Garcia:] The ease, convenience and utter
effectiveness of the steroid contraceptive
is universally felt to distinguish it from
other forms of contraception.
Never before in the history of the world have
the untoward effects
of pharmacological agents so consistently
and so confusingly been presented to a more
sophisticated world.
But clouding these issues are the fears of
the unknown itself,
criticisms from the persons opposing contraception
in any form,
and the bias of medical attitudes,
the belief that pregnancy is good and not
associated with hazards,
and then, further, moral issues are entertained.
Basically the education of physicians imbues
him with the philosophy,
the need, to preserve life and to avoid harmful
approaches.
This, moreover, is extended to mean that errors
of omission
are less serious, less ominous,
than the errors and the acts of comission.
Active contraception, because of this philosophy,
cannot be favored openly.
The concept of health however, must consider
the composite
of physical, mental, and social well-being,
rather than mere absence of infirmity and
disease.
The oral contraceptive by virtue of its utter
effectiveness,
and the convenience which it entertains,
contributes to the health of the individual,
despite the many disadvantages that have been
pointed to.
The irresponsible adverse comments about potential
harmful effects
do not contribute to the health of the individual.
Many of these accusations have been made.
Moreover, an unabated population press is
also menacing.
Actions of the pill affect all body systems
to a greater or lesser degree.
These actions are a resultant of the combination
of the end results
of both direct effects on target organs as
well as the indirect effects,
which are mediated by alterations induced
in the endocrinologically active areas.
The metabolic alterations that have been discussed
and pointed to as occurring with the use of
the oral contraceptives
have all been shown to be reversible when
these agents are discontinued.
Many of the reported effects are very difficult
to classify
as to whether they are drug-induced or nondrug-induced.
Causality and association may not be synonymous.
The epidemiologic studies of themselves do
not resolve the matter convincingly,
Although there are massive data, there are
no truly comparative studies
nor are the statistics of sufficient validity
to resolve the association and causality controversy
with absolutism.
Clinical judgment is very much required.
Physicians cannot shirk their responsibility.
They must use care and continued supervision
in prescribing and in supervising
and caring for the subjects using this form
of contraception.
There is no effective, no more effective approach
to contraception that can be pointed to,
and prevention of pregnancy must be considered an all-or-none principle.
The purported risks of oral contraceptives
are of small incidence,
and by and large are outweighed by the apparent
risks
associated with pregnancy and even the toll
of daily living.
No pharmacological agent can be considered
to be totally safe.
Individuality is cherished, making an ideal
contraceptive almost impossible to achieve.
Many more effective and convenient ones are
needed.
[Dr. Segal:] Dr. Lasagna, would you make your
opening statement please?
[Dr. Lasagna:] Yes, since the beginning of
the modern era of chemotherapy,
since the time of Paul Ehrlich, let us say,
those interested in the development of new
chemicals have been searching for magic bullets,
for drugs that would pick out the offending
microorganism
or would hit a specific organ in the body,
and leave relatively untouched the rest of
the body,
leave the patient relatively unharmed.
Almost without exception, perhaps without
exception one should say,
this dream of a magic bullet has not been
fulfilled.
Drugs are more like buckshot than they are
like magic bullets,
and the oral contraceptives in my opinion
illustrate this beautifully.
As has been already said, they seem to hit
almost every cell in the body.
With each passing year we have become aware
of the ability
of these chemicals to affect many parts of
the body.
We have heard of changes in the skin, changes
in the hair,
alterations in libido,
not always in the appropriate direction.
We've heard of changes in the liver,
disturbances in blood-clotting,
with thromboembolic phenomena manifesting themselves
in various parts of the body.
We've heard of depression apparently associated
with some women with the use of the pill.
We've heard of severe and excruciating migrainous
headaches
developing in some women for the first time
on starting oral contraceptives.
We are now beginning to develop more and more
a fear
of the potential for development of cancer
in either the breasts or the genital tract
in women exposed for years to these hormones.
Now, when one takes all of those reports,
and this buckshot capacity of these powerful
chemicals,
and combines that with the knowledge that
other methods of contraception are available,
which, while are not quite as effective as
the oral contraceptives,
are nevertheless, in the hands of many women, extraordinarily effective,
I believe it irresponsible for a physician
to look upon these pills
as a method of first choice for most or all
women desiring birth control.
[Dr. Segal:] Well, we have an interesting
situation here in which Dr. Lasagna,
you believe that it's irresponsible for physicians
to be prescribing the pill
as the contraceptive of first choice,
and you Dr. Garcia, believe that it's irresponsible
to be criticizing the potential hazards of
the pill.
[Dr. Lasagna:] I said not for all women as
a method of first choice,
I believe it is the method of first choice
for some.
[Dr. Segal:] Right.
I think that there probably exists a difficulty
here
in defining just what the precise position
of each discussant is.
Perhaps I could help to resolve this by asking
two pointed questions, one to each of you.
To you, Dr. Lasagna, I would ask do you believe
that the oral contraceptives
as are now being used should be withdrawn
from the market?
And to you, Dr. Garcia, do you believe that
the safety of these drugs
is adequate to permit their widespread use
without medical prescription?
Dr. Lasagna?
[Dr. Lasagna:] While I have for some years
now
been beating the drum, trying to alert people
to the possible hazards
of the oral contraceptives.
I have never and do not today espouse to physicians
that these medicaments should be removed from
the market.
I think they continue to play a very important
role in birth control.
[Dr. Garcia:] There is no question
that the controversy that exists
is really not as deep as it appears at first glance.
On the one hand, it's a matter of how one
weighs out the relative merit.
There is no question that, as I indicated
in my opening statement,
that the physician cannot shirk his responsibility.
He has to supervise his patients adequately,
completely.
He cannot just prescribe the oral contraceptive,
nor can the oral contraceptive be dispensed
over the counter, nor in slot machines.
There are sufficient warnings from the studies
and epidemiological reviews,
and while they do not point with absolute
[inaudible],
I quite concur that these must not be left
unheeded.
One must continue to review the problem with
this very much in mind.
However, the aspect of the hazards of not
taking the oral contraceptives
and when I say not taking the oral contraceptive,
I am really referring to not taking or not
using really effective methods of family planning.
And when you get down below six pregnancies
per 100 women a year,
you are dealing with relatively effective
methods.
Above this, and most of the methods that have
been evaluated
and not associated with the need for a physician,
are in the category of being relatively ineffective.
And when you're dealing with this, as I indicated
also,
the need for considering the philosophy that contraception is an all-or-none principle.
When a woman comes to me she, doesn't want to be half-safe,
she wants to have complete protection, this is what she's asking for.
The unwanted pregnancy raises the great scepter
and I think here we have increases in maternal and fetal mortality,
we have increases in other morbidities,
we have increased hazards of the induced abortion itself,
even in the best of hands there are hazards
with this approach.
There are increases in the undesirable marriages
that might result without the availability
of effective contraception.
There are also the trauma and other features
with regard to illegitimacy and the increase
in the undesirable parental behavior
towards the offspring, which I've seen with
great frequency in our society today.
[Dr. Segal:] Dr. Garcia, I don't think there's
any argument about the relative advantages
to the woman and to society at large derived
from the use of contraception.
I think it's sometimes unfortunate that people
consider as synonyms
contraception on the one hand and oral contraception
on the other.
Many of the benefits in terms of maternal
health of which you speak
are derived from virtually all effective contraception,
and for women in many of our socioeconomic
classes, effective contraception includes
not only oral contraception but the intelligent
use of the diaphragm,
use of the intrauterine device,
and in fact the intelligent use of the method
of periodic abstinence.
But I think that from the response that both
of you made,
it's clear that you have each weighed the
equation of relative risk and benefit,
and come to the conclusion that there is enough
safety in the use of oral contraceptives
to warrant the continuation of its use in
the country.
So let us focus now on the question of these
hazards and risks,
so that those in the audience can make their
own judgments
about this balance of the hazards on the one
hand
and the effectiveness and usefulness on the
other.
[Dr. Lasagna:] I'd just like to comment on...
[Dr. Segal:] Sure.
[Dr. Lasagna:] Dr. Garcia's statement about
women wanting 100 percent protection,
I don't think all women want 100 percent protection,
and I think this is one of the reasons why
there is such a tremendous variability
in the reports in the literature on the effectiveness
of such things as condoms and diaphragms.
I think the condom and the diaphragm used
compulsively
represent extraordinarily effective techniques.
But if you're casual about their use,
if you want a child or two sometime in the
future
and don't really care all that much whether
it occurs a year from now or two years from now,
I think one has a different approach to the
use of these mechanical devices
than the woman who has had four or five children,
considers her family complete,
and is darn likely to be compulsive about
the use of these techniques.
So that I think in the interest of individualizing
our approach to these women,
I think it would be unfortunate to give the
impression that every woman wants 100 percent protection...
furthermore, if I can just complete my thought,
with the oral contraceptives one doesn't have
100 percent protection,
at least not with the sequential ones, which
in my experience,
the number of anecdotal reports I've come
across,
talking with patients, with obstetricians,
the failure rate is significant there.
The protection is far from complete.
[Dr. Garcia:] Well, I quite agree that one
has to individualize;
however, I again, the point that one might
take at issue here,
mainly that the patient that has four or five
pregnancies
could likewise be categorized as being in
the upper age group,
where she's going to fall within the category
of having greater risk
with taking the oral contraceptives.
So it's not so simple a matter, and as a
gynecologist,
I don't know what your experience is as a
clinical pharmacologist,
but as a gynecologist,
when I query my patients they want an all-or-none sort of reassurance
and very few of them elect to take sequential
modalities.
[Dr. Segal:] Can we pass now to the question
of the hazards themselves,
you pointed to Dr. Lasagna's worldwide reputation
as a clinical pharmacologist,
so perhaps we should ask him about some of
these issues
that have been raised with respect to the
safety of the pill.
Let's take the cancer issue first.
Where does that stand and what are the real
facts in that situation, Dr. Lasagna?
[Dr. Lasagna:] I don't think there are a lot
of hard facts to go on here.
We have a long background of experimental
evidence suggesting that hormones
can be utilized in a number of animal models
to produce things like breast cancer, that's
clear.
The relevance of these studies to the use
of these hormones
in the variety of clinical states in which
they have been used
for a long time is unclear to me.
I think we're beginning to have reports on
certain changes
in the cells in the cervix that make one at
least worry more
than we've been worrying in the past,
and in my opinion, at the moment the issue
is an open one.
I think with the background that we have on
what these hormones can do in the laboratory,
it would be foolish to assume that we have
no worries,
but I also would say that at the moment, the
evidence implicating these oral contraceptives
in the production of any kind of cancer is
lacking.
I think the evidence, for example, is much
more compelling
in regard to thromboembolic disease.
[Dr. Segal:] Still for a moment on the cancer
issue--on the basis of the animal work,
isn't it more likely that the real concern is the breast rather the cervix?
[Dr. Lasagna:] I think so, yes.
[Dr. Segal:] And have there been any clinical
observations,
or let me put it even more fundamentally,
has anyone actually done a study that would
give us some idea
as to whether or not there is a causal relationship?
[Dr. Lasagnal:] I'm not aware of any.
It's a great pity, I think, that so little
attention has been paid
to the setting up of prospective studies to
monitor all these things
that we're concerned about and that we have
a hard time making definite statements about,
because we're stuck with retrospective analysis.
[Dr. Segal:] Dr. Garcia, you've been mostly involved with this.
[Dr. Garcia:] Attempts to set up prospective
studies have been, in later years, tried...
One of the greatest difficulties, and one
of the things that...
this is new to most of the scientific world
in clinical lines of investigation,
that is, to sample a denominator that is as
vast as is required
to measure small changes in the numerator,
is indeed a task that I don't know if it would
ever be accomplished
or not with reference to the oral contraceptives.
There's so many other factors that come into
the bias of selection and the like,
that it's difficult to do this, and what's
more, to try to have a truly controlled population
that is not using the steroid contraceptive
versus a [inaudible] contraceptive, is likewise very difficult
because the steroid contraceptive group feel more compelled
because of the adverse publicity to come
back to be seen more frequently.
While those on other techniques are much more
difficult to follow
and this has been one of the greatest pitfalls that we've had
in trying to arrange for prospective studies.
I don't know how to get around that.
[Dr. Segal:] But I think that there are good
epidemiologic methods
to account for this bias, or to take it into
account
in setting up the design of the study.
But let me turn to another issue,
I think the one that has been most firmly
established among the possible serious consequences
of the use of oral contraception has been
the epidemiologic studies and indications
of an increased risk of thromboembolic disease
associated with the use of the drug.
In studies both in Britain, and now on the
basis of the recent report
by the Advisory Committee of Obstetrics and Gynecology of the Food and Drug Administration
confirmed here in the United States.
Can you tell us how that stands and what your
view of that issue is, Dr. Garcia?
[Dr. Garcia:] I...there is a strong warning
that this presents.
I don't know that this conclusively proves
that there is a cause and effect relationship,
and I think that as I indicated previously,
epidemiologic reviews will not do this.
They are still lacking many of the mechanisms to explain
the occurrence of these thromboembolic and other effects,
and until this gap has been bridged to demonstrate
the mechanism of action
that will produce the effect,
we still will not have a cause and effect
relationship,
but nonetheless these studies are very carefully designed...
they are performed according to sound epidemiologic
principles,
and consistently, although with different
variants of incidence and points of comparison,
we have a concurrence with all of the studies indicating an association
between the use of oral contraceptives
and the occurrence of thrombophlebitis,
and also consistently that risk is seen greater in the older age group than the younger age group.
[Dr. Lasagna:] May I comment on the quality
of the evidence linking the contraceptives
to...oral contraceptives to clotting,
one thing I know something about is the difficulty
of linking drugs
to side effects that are said to be associated
with them.
But in my opinion, the evidence on this point
is so good as to be very compelling,
at least it's so much better than we usually
have for other drugs
that I think one can't ignore the evidence.
The evidence exists in my opinion, not only
in the form of epidemiologic data,
but in the clotting studies that have been
done,
which in almost all instances have shown a
change in women taking these pills
in the direction of increased clotting.
The peculiar distribution of some of these
clots that they're seeing,
women coming in with clots in the veins of
their arms, a most unusual phenomenon.
Clots in the vertebral arteries in young women,
a most unusual neurological picture, and then
the challenge cases,
the women who develop recurrent thrombophlebitis
each time they're given the pill.
There aren't a lot of those,
but there are enough I think to represent
a legitimate challenge type of evidence.
[Dr. Garcia:] But this sort of bizarre type
of location of thromboembolic phenomenon is not new,
it's just that it hasn't been focused attention on in association
with the use of oral contraceptives, number
one,
and secondly we have to also consider that...uh...
[Dr. Segal:] I'm afraid, Dr. Garcia, I'm not
going to let you finish your thought because
our time is up.
In the few seconds left to us,
I'd like to attempt a brief summary of this
discussion.
It seems to me that we have reached a consensus
that this is a type of medication that does
involve risk.
Both participants agree that the risk is not
so great
to warrant removal of these drugs from the
physician's armamentarium.
I think that both agree also, however,
that when these drugs are used, they must
be used under very careful supervision
and although the point wasn't raised I feel
confident that both would agree
that the labeling instructions required
by the Food and Drug Administration should
be adhered to very strictly.
As with all drugs, there is a question of
relative risk versus relative advantage,
in determining safety.
On that basis and by that definition,
it seems that there is an element of safety
sufficient for continuation of the use of
oral contraceptives.
[Host:] We thank Dr. Celso-Ramon Garcia, Dr.
Louis Lasagna, and Dr. Sheldon Segal
for their interesting analysis of a critical
problem in patient care.
In subsequent programs, we shall continue
to record equally significant
concepts and controversies in modern medicine,
The opinions expressed on this program do
not necessarily constitute endorsement
by the Department of Health, Education and Welfare, the Public Health Service, or its constituents.
[Music]